[Music]
but it was Philip William Mick and I'm
from Overland II you know I was gonna
bullied ever since second grade third
grade fourth grade and fifth grade they
were teasing on me picking on me and all
that it was getting really bad and I
thought this might need to be fixed
[Music]
I was scared bullied for many years
people start cursing at me because
they're learning off rich stuff and I'm
just wearing cheap stuff cuz my parents
care for the rich stuff they were called
me fatso because of my weight
my mom had enough of it she stepped in
talked with Brett and he helped me bite
in all these bikers together to help me
stop the bully I'm Brent Warfield
director of United motorcycle
enthusiasts we ride together and help
support our local communities do charity
work we ride to do good it's a
brotherhood
get along instead of being hate you get
along with you gotta love it it started
on the first day of school we met a
restaurant 50 bikers were there the
bikers took me to school to support and
tell all those people that bullying
isn't cool and stop it and so saying it
they showed it don't dolly
few people would understand actually
there's tons of people now there's a lot
of kids who want to be my friends it
just relieves all my feelings and all
that
it was my first time on a motorcycle
if they like I was flying
[Music]
yeah bra returns saw bullying because
make kids bake that the boys the big guy
but really the big guy is actually you
[Music]
pay attention to your children teacher
kids empathy open your heart up see how
you would feel love is the answer
[Music]